Melissa hey Braun above all I'll see
your father what were the emotions today
around seeing brawny commit to USC
um
uh first of all congratulations to my
son oh and um
I know
his next journey and picking a a great
University in USC
you know I'm proud of him
this is uh an incredible thing I was I
think I told Mike after the game
you know unless it was like one of my
you know great grandmothers or
great-grandfathers or someone that I was
way before my time
to my knowledge of this is the first one
out of the James gang to go to college
obviously his dad didn't go to school
his mom didn't go to college
you know I think my mom went stepped on
maybe stepped on campus for a little bit
you know maybe a community college or
something but
she had my little ass running around so
she couldn't spend much time in the
classroom 19 years old she couldn't do
that I was three
um
so it's a
very very very very very
exciting very humbling
and great moment for for our family you
know it's just uh super cool he's a
great kid
USC is getting a great kid I would say
he's there to play basketball but uh
you know they're going to be a super uh
surprised how great of a kid he is even
though they've been recruiting for quite
a while